said he was looking for the URL uh just
gone live
hello good morning good afternoon good
evening wherever the hell you are in the
world and welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel
um
our plan for what we were going to talk
about on this life has kind of gone out
of the window
um well that changed can I can I go on
the edge I don't like being in the
middle okay
um
so guys if you're thinking this is going
to be quite big news
so if you if you like Stargate
um share this video now tell everybody
immediately that we've gone live and
we've got some breaking quite exciting
news so let's just very quickly do the
um intro and then we'll go from there
[Music]
I feel like I should scrap names
actually sort of accidentally write
names down because I've been um
scribbling things things down
so hi Sarah hi Laura hey Nick Shirley's
in the house and Geordie hello everybody
so
um
so where to start with this so I've
literally just told you guys what's
going on
um but we should actually do the uh
the thing you create oh first of all how
are you guys
doing well I'm all right just get get on
with it
[Music]
stormy's here
uh right so stormy doesn't know any of
this because you've just arrived I don't
know [__] I will tell you I'll tell you
a bit more detail than I'm not allowed
to say live after the the stream stormy
but so
um did I leave that comment I'm sorry
hide that
smoking through Chris you're in sci-fi
Chris death
brain pain this is quite big news I wish
I could tell you more but basically I
had an email
um on Friday
and that actually had um and I could say
this it was and if it was the correct
MGM email so you put it that way so
there's an email from MGM
um this was somebody that works for an
executive for MGM and they were actually
authorized for once to actually talk to
us and tell us a little bit of
information they said they are reaching
out
to a couple of
um YouTube channels
um and um and other on you know
influences and things because they want
to start putting
um a bit of clarity out there about
what's coming
um they don't want so many rumors
knocking around they want to sort of
like tell people what is actually
happening
so
um I immediately checked this person out
I went through a couple of my sources
and I got very excited to found out it
wasn't somebody trying to wind me up it
was actually this person and they do
actually work for this person so Happy
Days
um
so they agreed to chat with me today and
I've spoken to them today
and they've been able to tell me a few
bits and Bobs about what's actually
going on with Stargate and a couple of
other projects as well she told me a
couple of things about RoboCop as well
which um I half listened to because I
was trying to get to talk about Stargate
I was just like want to tell me about
robocopter did they tell you anything
about the thing we're all wanting to
know Legally Blonde three is going to be
a prequel
legally blown through though is is
obviously happening I mean come on right
so
and then we'll break it down and talk
about it I'll go through the headlines
right so
um
Jordan peel was the director that we've
been talking about for the last few
weeks that apparently was approached
about doing Stargate
they met him several times apparently
but they have now decided they will not
be moving ahead with Jordan peel which
we found out about a week and a half ago
actually but we haven't got around
um so he will not blind thing but this
person said that even though that is
true that they're not moving ahead to
Jordan peel they do have a director now
they what she kept saying was they know
who the director will be
um I push and say if they signed on is
that like is that going to be official
and she said we know who it's going to
be
and I said she then but it could be he
could be I don't know or are they
um so I wonder if that's a similar thing
that we heard when we were talking about
Jordan peel that he refused to sign on
while
um the strikes were going on
um so I wonder if it's a similar thing
going on there
um so they know who it is there is a
production team in place at MGM so there
are apparently three producers that are
now officially sort of signed on as the
production team for Stargate wouldn't
tell me who they are
um they do have a script so the movie
has a script
and that is 100 definite I asked if it
was Mark Fergus
and she said she just smiled and said
she can't talk about that
but she's mine so we can maybe maybe
um
the one interesting thing actually is
um there's been no definite decision on
a cinematic release she did say we are
right there is
um that is an idea and that is been
pushed by she just said hire Amazon
Executives want a cinematic movie
um okay
um if she didn't say any more than that
but what she was saying was there's been
no definite decision for that decision
will be made in the next couple of weeks
very shortly there's going to be
defective but it will be a movie we are
getting a movie whether it's straight to
stream or straight to cinema is has not
been 100 decided
um which will be followed very quickly
by a TV series
and she did confirm that
um and then we sort of chatted a bit
about Amazon's how excited or interested
Amazon are with Stargate and she sort of
said that um or he could be he
um Bond was always James Bond was always
the main motivation for buying MGM that
was always the you know that's the
golden Hoops
um but whenever they talk about projects
they're developing and their strategy to
what they're going to do with MGM over
the next decade start Stargate is in the
middle of it every every conversation
Dr James Bond
another another couple of other big
franchises and but they always talk
about Stargate
right for so yeah I can't tell you who
the executive producer is that's
involved in this
but they are senior this is the this is
the only I should say this is the only
time I've ever spoken
I didn't expect directly to them
obviously but this isn't I've ever spoke
to normally my sources are like the
cleaner and things like that and you
know like um I I got a good sources in
like the legal side of things but
they're literally the people like admin
you know so they're the sort of sources
I speak to this is the first time
an official Source has ever come forward
so it's like it's amazing like a
production developer or like a
representative from an executive there
they work for the executive
they did she has got a title but I
forget what it was basically like a PA
that was why I I took it
um but they've got some long title I've
got it on the email I'll have to have a
look I can't tell you anyway
um but anyway so
um is that we know who this executive I
obviously know who this executive is and
looking at what they do
it seems that the rumors about this
maybe being filmed in Europe
suggestive and the TV series is like
definite because this woman wouldn't
have anything to do with it if there
wasn't TV related and I'm not saying any
more than that and I think that might be
saying too much to be honest so I'm
hoping I'll get smack on the wrists the
one thing she did say is though that
when the official
announcements
cousin it is
it's their pet dog this is that that's
who's been an email I missed their pack
dog
yeah tell me how much they love I love
my boss I love my boss so much my boss
is nice I love my boss
um so um
yeah this person wouldn't be contacting
us if it wasn't a TV series as well
because that would be their area so
um
but yeah so the one thing they said to
us is that they will be willing to give
us
um if she sort of said if the
relationship
works or words to that effect basically
if they can trust us I think where was
that they were going with it so I think
this is this is like a very tentative
initial
introduction and then see what we
actually do with it and I've been very
careful to sort of say throughout my
allowed to say that in my lab say this
um and and she's she's agreed sort of
thing
or he'll be here
um so basically if the relationship
things and they seem they believe they
can trust us we need to make this
channel a gender neutral Channel
everyone is today them there
what word Pops in my brain
um
we're so woke oh my God
you are
um
I'm like
well not me right so those are the
headlines so do you want to if we break
it down first of all what do you think
about we've discussed the Jordan peel
was lined up for this and they're
actually MGM were quite Keen
I'm shocked that you even said his name
in general my face you play this back
you'll see me going he just said the
name like but I can throw them aloud so
yeah I was told by the original Source a
couple of days ago that I was I was
allowed to
what do you think about that I I
and I mentioned that there's a bit of
controversy maybe around this director
um and I I wonder if it's maybe a
probably a probably a good thing to be
honest even though I think I really
respect him as a director and I think he
would have done an amazing job
I think the wokists would have got
that would have put wind in their sails
sort of thing
I don't even know about that as much as
I love Jordan peel he is the three
things that he has directed so far even
though the last thing was various feels
Bergen
are very unique to him
and that's what worried me the most
whenever you started saying like oh well
the guy that might be directing is
talking about a full reboot or talking
about this or at least leaning towards
that and just that that alone was enough
to just make me not as excited for
Jordan piola's the last couple months
that you've kind of mentioned it to us
because you remember my face when you
said Jordan peel the first time I was
ecstatic yeah well I got you know since
you're saying that this is more you know
could be European production and the
only really controversial director I can
think of it has to work in Europe would
be Roman Polanski
I mean it can't be Roman police it just
that would be a very different movie
probably a good one but not I mean you
said Europe and then controversial
director and what the
I mean can you imagine I mean God
just saying I'm just bringing it up you
know we pretty sure it is not
no it's not Roman Polanski
we've tamped down that rumor tree at
least we've done something easy for this
tag
what do you think Matt is that uh maybe
a
probably in the bigger picture probably
a good thing um I I am kind of happy
that he's not
for the same reason Harry said about the
fact that he he
kind of would lead towards a hard reboot
I don't I've always been against that
anyway
um
yeah I don't the whole thing is exciting
the whole thing is exciting that there's
movement the fact it's in Europe
he's good because they can get around
the whole strike thing
I love it anyway we're going to talk
about the strikes in a minute
I I dropped a bond that one of the
people I spoke to said there can't be
Studios have said November 1st this has
got to be over we want to work but he
was actually talking about um so I
talked to him a bit about it since and
he was saying a lot of the thing is a
lot of the um
uh Networks they always do big like
Christmas specials and stuff and they
normally film in the summer and they
haven't filmed they haven't gotten
and they're like we really really want
to do some of these like Christmasy
special type things
um and so the studios but then like the
streaming services are thinking like all
of our next summer Productions they
should be filming now come on sort of
thing so they've sort of said November
1st was they do not want this to go any
further
and you're looking at deadline over the
last two days I think the wga might be
resolved today
it's really looking like and I think
whatever the wga The Writers Guild agree
I think the actors will follow I think
the the deal they go will be pretty
similar so that I think this could be
over in the next week
it'd be nice because aren't getting
official announcements of things and I
think I wonder if that's why this woman
is um Oman is approaching us yeah
because the ball is rolling I need to be
your PA advisor don't I your PR advisor
yeah you do I nominate Matt to be your
PA advisor
I mean I'm already I'm already is like
PR guy on like emails to to somebody but
I'm not going to say who to some people
yeah we the emails go through you
because I say what I think I'll say
certain things and that's a problem
next week you'll see Jamie with one of
those little like FBI little dangles
behind us here and it's just me Matt
just
don't say
it's a good girl from shut up Matt to
Jamie hold up real quick very quickly
yeah shut up
um but yeah I I think we've I
bought it because I think he did done a
great job but I think it's probably the
best thing in the whole yeah
if he wasn't going down if he was going
to do a continuation probably it'd be
all right but
uh uh uh you could have the greatest
director in the world if if you said to
me that they were going to do a hard
reboot I'd be I'd be not invested yeah
that's where I'm at um Laura's just made
the point because they've gone for gone
Kapoor um which is a major Jewish artist
that's why they um had meetings
yesterday and they've had meetings today
as well so I mean they're they don't
normally work weekends and they're the
top Executives you know like bug Iger
and people like they're they're there
either in person or virtually involved
in these meetings and if you read the
deadline
over the last few days the Articles
they've been saying it's it feels very
close it feels like they're like
the last few dot in the eyes and drop
the t's and they said it's just really a
little bit of
um okay
um it's just like it feels like it's
just like a AI still a little bit
um
I'm not doing a reaction to the Doctor
Who trailer on my channel I'm not
I've seen so many people do these
reactions to trailers and they're also
boring
I don't want to make boring content
there's a 15 minute video reacting to a
90-second trail I saw today
I watched this guy I've been watching
him for a while he's a lovely guy
um
but he literally put the trailer on and
he pulled it on 0.5 uh playback speeding
but we're gonna watch his frame by a
frame and he's there pausing it every
two seconds I'm like it's a two minute
video of 0.5 like frames and you're
pausing it it's gonna it took 15 minutes
to get through I'm like please just I
turned it off I couldn't watch it and
I'm like that's why I'm not going to do
that that kind of content I like Doctor
Who but dear God yeah yeah but when the
Stargate trailer comes out I'll be
watching it at 0.5
yeah but then what you'll do is you'll
make notes and then you'll do a reaction
you won't do it live
I might do like a reaction live just for
the comedy value of me going like you
know when the Star Wars trailer come out
I mean just going
[Music]
for like 90 seconds and then I might I
might do that but then I will then just
talk about it but yeah we'll see we'll
figure something out uh
the other big headline they know no
definitive answer on Cinema release but
it is going to be a movie house did you
wanna without saying names did you want
to add that little bit you mentioned
oh yeah well I can say one name uh just
just Chambers the guy that I interviewed
a couple about a month month and a half
ago now on M Cube check out that video
If you haven't seen it yet of course uh
say what can you tell us who he is oh
yeah he's a playwright author his wife
is a big producer at Disney and has a
bunch of stuff going on etc etc you can
look up all that good stuff I don't know
if I should say it but you got the
information a piece to piece of puzzle
together uh but he was talking to some
friends of his he's lived here for 20 25
years his wife is
had the most successful Disney show of
the past few decades so know some people
uh talk to some people at MGM and he was
like y'all y'all are totally right
people are definitely getting Stargate
together
so just just an extra source of
information that there is a Stargate
movie and or TV show coming our way you
know or both this man's the one that
name is chamber Stevens chamber Stevens
yes yes so we're getting more I think I
have him on Facebook I think I added him
but I'm not sure if he accepts you
should
I I think I did but I don't know if he
accepted I can't remember oh I'll tell
him he's doesn't pay attention back on
soundtrack we did he did agree but then
I forgot to follow it up so yeah I can
do that any day any game of the week we
were literally striking uh on the picket
lines on Friday morning it was three
days in I think they're either four or
five days into the agreements and
hopefully finishing everything up now
but the Talk of the Town is that it's
almost over and we're all very excited
to actually get back to work and get
moving again which yeah y'all know I'm
ready for yeah past ready for
um
so no definitive decision on Cinema how
do we feel about that
but but movie we are getting movie
I mean for me it's almost like at least
it seems like it's moving forward
you know I mean
itself yeah
I understand
it's probably gonna be more there's
probably more eyes if it was streaming
anyway
just because of how few people now go to
the cinema
yeah
so I know it's a controversial thing
people don't go to the cinema people
should go to the cinema because you
should support whatever you want but
people don't because
money
it's just easier to stream there's so
many reasons why people don't yeah so
yeah going on to a streaming service is
going to be
it's gonna get the most eyes possible
maybe they'll do both though maybe
they'll do it on streaming and also have
a cinema release which which is very
which is what kind of happened like a
limited Cinema release which is kind of
what's popular in a few years
um I think there's still a Prestige to a
cinematic movie I've done a video
talking about this tomorrow while I was
walking on the beach this morning so I
won't say too much about that but I
think there's a there's a
um
The Prestige to it and like it shows
Amazon are really confident about this
if they're willing to like push that out
but they're trying to become a cinema
production company they want to speak
feature films and the fact that if they
if that's where they'll go but no
different decision
thank you BK Dan and thank you for the
contribution sir yeah if you've got
questions guys throw them in but if you
uh if you do it as a um
I feel like if Amazon are gonna do a
cinema release
and it'd be big it will be the bond if
they when they do it
that's gonna have much more that's gonna
have much more of an impact but then
that will be there lots of people you're
right I think a lot of people would get
over there whatever their version is to
theaters these days just to see it on
the big screening for like the audience
kind of
um communal kind of response I think
you're right I think you're absolutely
right
I think we'll be less likely to get like
an sg1 Revival with many of the original
cast back if they do a cinematic movie
yeah we could basically get an sg1
Revival full-on Daniel Jackson Sam
Rich you know O'Neill even and we you
know Christopher Judge we could get that
sort of film I think if it's at the
cinema we won't I think it'll be more
um
RDA I'm gonna scream
when it happens man I'm sorry I'm asking
Brad about that
I'm gonna say that he's then all of you
people that keep telling me that's a
stupid idea if Brad agrees with me
you'll all have to shut up and if he
doesn't I'll have to show them
so I'm asking
um
so
what I'm sorry you guys so yeah cinnamon
still a risk but you know at least
they're open to it and
honestly after sitting sitting with it
and thinking about it the way we have
the last couple months really
I then need to do a cinema release over
a TV series I to begin with
a TV series feels safe and even though
it's what we want and we want it it
feels boring it doesn't feel like they
actually care it feels like they would
be doing a cash grab just for Nostalgia
and all these different little tick
marks instead of actually caring and
applying that risk to something that yes
has a bunch of nostalgic factors but has
a future
on our screens and not just we're going
to run out of nostalgia quick if that's
all we're going for we have 17 seasons
and a couple TV movies and another film
to jump off of that's we can get some
seasons of fun seasons of nostalgia
but we need a future for this franchise
and I think a movie is the way to set
that up I I think a TV show no matter
what you're gonna be bogged down at
least for half a season trying to
correlate it with things that have
happened in the past you might as well
do do a little bit of that do a little
bit of that leg work in a movie and and
introduce new people as well I honestly
a movie if it was just the occasional SG
person that we're familiar with just in
the background or as a commander
somewhere doing something that would be
great because it it shows us there's
more to this world still and it's not so
much like okay we got actually one back
we got SGA back and we're gonna get
bored so fast even as much as we don't
necessarily want to admit it we would
love to see it but it would just be it
it's not going anywhere if they don't
allow it to go anywhere and I think that
they need to allow it to have that room
and breadth
yeah does that make sense I do agree
with everything you've just said
um I just go on top of that having
cameos from like the previous cast
members would give us reassurance it's
in the same universe yeah yeah it's not
like a reboot it's not um
soft reboot or anything it's the same
universe exactly the same it's just
continuing maybe with different
characters but
that's the link to say it's the same
same sg1 same SGA this view that you
know and love it's just different
characters now because it's been 15
years
yeah that has to be part of it if
they're just mentioned if we actually
see them or anything I think that has to
be a part of it but I think the good
thing about doing a movie as well is it
even if it's not super successful if
Amazon's already invested in Stargate
which they seemingly are they know the
type of audience they have with it there
is already a baked in TV audience if the
movie fails you can still make a TV show
and still have a money-making audience
there and I think that's the best thing
is because they could bring in way more
people than we have already plus get
everybody back you have something for
new people you have something for old
people you have something to get both of
them excited about new things still
and we just have more Stargate like that
just sounds best to me honestly I don't
I don't know and anybody that says the
um the cinema release would fail I have
to say
10 times gross in MGM movie of all time
the original Stargate the highest
grossing movie of all time whenever it
was released as well
what about that it was it was king at
the box office when it came out yeah
yeah absolutely smashed it because it
only cost them like 15 million quid to
get old get their hands on as well
um
third highest search YouTube searches of
sci-fi shows Stars Star Trek Star Wars
Stargate those two other two shows are
still on and they get searches Stargate
hasn't been on screens for 12 years the
third highest that's mental damn excuse
me Facebook groups there's hundreds I've
said it before the fact that channels
like ours does well
that's not been off the air for so long
just proves that there's a there's an
appetite for it
I'm sorry
I'm sorry I was just gonna I didn't mean
to interrupt I'm just gonna say there's
one only one other franchise that comes
to mind that had that kind of staying
power and that was Star Trek
in terms of all the production the
number of spin-offs the number of
episodes all you know in the the
reaction to the fandom decades decades
afterwards shows that Stargate is it's
in King Modi territory
is probably in a similar yeah yeah yeah
but very much at the time I think
probably more in the UK than anywhere
else in the world
right um we will be very very careful
with spoilers once this is officially
announced and things start happening
like um we'll announce actors and things
when it's in the public domain but if we
hear anything that by the way we haven't
got three million views we've got 4.2
million
damn it
um we will be very careful and to be
honest Steph there I've I've known
things
um things like um I found it little bits
about Brad script or I was I was offered
to told a little bit about Bradford and
I didn't want to be told because I don't
want it ruined I I don't want to ruin
the movie for me so if I'm offered
information about story and stuff like
that to be honest even though I know it
would be brilliant for the channel I'll
say no because I don't want to know
um I don't know that sounds really
stupid but I don't want to know
it's like it's like opening my Christmas
presents um you know like two weeks
before you know like peering in under
the wrapping paper so there's there are
certain things that 100 we will share if
we find out
um like we do but there's things that I
don't want to know sorry I won't share
with you
um makes sense
um it's just I don't know when it is
by then which I hope we [__] we
probably have but we really need to at
some point we need to go together yeah I
can make Dudley is just down the road
foreign
literally are just down the road it's
ridiculous that we still haven't haven't
like met face to face driving soon so
I'll just yeah yeah well yeah but I'm
I'm lazy am I
um so yeah yeah I could I could come
down at any point next couple of
weekends let's do it so
um movie big big big big thing though
definitely getting a TV series it's
basically already been green lit as far
as we're concerned so
yay
thank you Double A's oh yes lots of
years
I mean again anybody saying anything
that the Cinema's a bad idea in a way I
don't care because the series is already
lined up yeah so that's the thing like
it it is the sleeping China sci-fi even
if it fails it will probably fails with
quotation marks everywhere around it
it'll probably still break even you know
the only thing that would make it not
break even is if it's just marketed like
a mother you know and they just have it
where it's just they spend three times
the mark the actual Budget on marketing
like that's the only way I could see it
not breaking even they they don't need a
marketing budget all they need to do is
tell us when it says
legitimately sometimes we will run our
mouth about it
send me a couple T-shirts
it's been nice do we haven't shut up
about it for two years
um it's the sleeping giant I sometimes
think goes I can't do another Stargate
video I can't I've got yeah I can and
but then I just think that's great
that's what I want to talk about Society
that's what I want to talk about
um
the motivation then for getting Stargate
again is that a big that that's got to
be again another big thumbs up in it
that that is again for an official
Source from MGM is telling us it was
Stargate was always one of the big which
is what we heard
way way way ago I mean the the beautiful
thing about why this sources was she's
basically confirmed everything we've
been talking about and she's not really
told us we're wrong about anything which
is just great it just confirms that you
know the people we're talking to know
what they're on about and which is
always a concern sometimes when you get
told certain things like I think you're
mental or just wrong but always try not
to share that stuff too much
um but again
they've got confidence in this that's
that's what I just can't help but feel
excited about
yeah incredible everyone says sleeping
jazz came to sleep people no they wake
up at some point because a sleeping
tonight that keeps on sleeping is dead
it's a dead giant seven times got to get
up and go weak I'm just saying yeah
comatose giant it's a sleeping giant
it's having a good night it's had a
12-year nap 14 year nap
um but it's gonna wake up even people in
comas wake up
yeah always
but yeah they just die but
um I I think we're well passed I I
personally I think we were well past the
will it won't it happen like
nine months ago ten months ago
um definitely marched 100 March I was
just like that's it's happening that's
it now
um
anybody that still thinks this is
happening I just thinking I'm sorry
you're just wrong I mean I think it's a
first year deal the second Amazon bottom
GM
that's it's pretty damn sure right after
that
you see comments all the time on on
Facebook on YouTube on Reddit especially
when when someone will post not
necessarily our videos but something
along the lines or Stargates coming back
and then they're always just like oh I
believe it when I see it or there's
nothing official been announced and I
think that's probably just
a lot of fans throughout the last 15
years have been promised things yeah and
then it's been ripped from ripped from
underneath them yeah
um
so hopefully this time well it will
happen but it is happening yeah it's
gonna it's gonna
reinvigorate their trust in the system
and there are several people that have
put comments on and I've said come back
to me when it's announced and they
better because I'm gonna go
straight up called me a liar and I'm
like I know who you are I have a list
now I really don't care that much but
I'm like just go back through my
comments go I know where you live yeah I
know where you live I know you're in a
thigh like Nations
um
uh yes we're not allowed to say that
um Americans a bit upset at us so ah I
think I think we got some because I'm
I'm we've got something coming up in
mid-october and that I think is going to
be really exciting that we can't talk
too much about but we we hope it's going
to happen
I'm not going to say definitely but I'm
thinking we can even get an announcement
by it I think we could get an
announcement within a couple of weeks of
the strikes ending
I really do
would be great
okay I think Harry's excited he's a very
happy lady and a member for anyone thank
you very much for being a member
um we love you Gary
um and she didn't blow away last week
middle of a hurricane
but she's very good it didn't blow away
excellent
um but yeah so just to recap then very
quickly
an official source of MGM has come
forward and basically clarified a few
bits definitely going to be a movie it's
not 100 gonna be Cinema though they
haven't actually decided it'll be in the
next couple of weeks they have got a
script they have got a director or at
least they know who the director is
going to be there is a production team
at MGM
um and Stargate has always been a major
motivator for why
Amazon bought MGM in the first place
so we actually have
something new um Dave pieces have we got
any news on the cast they're not at that
stage yet they're not there yet
so
um
we know certain actors have been very
tentatively approached We Believe Amanda
Tapping has been tentatively approached
and we believe Michael Shank says and we
believe
um I know for a fact that
um the person whose name has now gone
out of my [__] head that played Rush
about something
um but it seemed to be that's when they
were um about what storyline they were
going to do
ah
um in the development stage so they sort
of very so they had a few ideas and they
seemed to be approaching their act to go
in if we did this be interested sort of
thing so I'm no more than that has been
has been done because obviously it's not
there's no point doing
a massive grip with Robert Carlisle is
rushing it for some for whatever reason
even if it's only a small part if he has
no intention of doing it so you sort of
tentatively sort of go would they
um and
um so we'll have to see but but we
believe that has but the casting won't
happen until
um
basically after the strikes anyway
because all the actors are on strike so
they couldn't approach them anyway
at least they couldn't sign up I don't
know how it would work about sort of
like talking to agents and asking
whether there's probably been some sort
of like off the record conversations but
nothing official
yeah they can't legally do anything
official just yet almost yeah but also
there's a script you'd think that at
very least the one or two if there are
returning actors have been at least
tentatively approached and let's be
honest very few of them are going to be
busy enough to say no
is not saying no to this
um man's attacking probably wouldn't
even though she is busy but no she
wouldn't see every every Comic Con she's
done for the last 10 years she says
she's always asked and she always says
I'd be there in a heartbeat
um who would be too busy to come back
just thinking about it for a sake see
what's on there on their IMDb listing
I I think I've just I've done my head I
would think my uh Michael judge
Christopher Judge would be a little
harder just because all this video game
stuff and he still acts a bunch
um well there's also the rumor going on
that he might end up being the God of
War so
um which I don't as much as would be
great I just don't I don't see that
happening
last time I heard they were they would
definitely tempted to approach but then
um the strikes happened
I I um they were definitely willing to
at least have the conversation with him
so and I think it would be a popular
choice
but it would be a dangerous one yeah
he's not young enough to carry something
like that I don't think right now he's
still built like a brick shot or
something built like a brick yeah but it
depends I guess if they're going back
with like just the the Norse god of war
aspect of things or if they're going
back further when Kratos need to be
younger I've never played the games but
I love the lore so they could write that
around the person but um also there's
the fact that he's not very Nordic
in appearance
um you put enough paint on somebody it
doesn't really matter at the end of the
day honestly
yeah so anything about Fergus um I asked
I got a smile and I got told they
couldn't answer that
that might be
um just this is just something just
realizing actually there are going to be
legal reasons why they she kind of can't
or he Cannon can't tell me certain
things I want to because like if penguin
and Parker were actually negotiating at
the moment and it wasn't all like signed
yeah there might be reasons why they
they can't confirm that because it maybe
isn't even confirmed I'm just thinking
that there are probably lots of legal
reasons why they can't say certain
things
there's no one out there yeah a lot of
the things it's it's uh just
everything's frozen because of the
strike you know maybe make a meeting
but they wouldn't be able to negotiate
anything they wouldn't be able to agree
on anything but they could take a
meeting and chat and talk but there's
lots of things they can't do because of
the Striking would be you know I mean we
saw what happened to Drew Barrymore when
she said oh yeah I'm just gonna go into
production
s they don't want to go shopping but
they want to announce
they don't want a little Channel with 26
000 subscribers to be able to get the
world exclusive on certain things
so I mean why they why they wouldn't I
don't know
and we've told you literally everything
else first so
you may as well
um but um but yeah there's going to be
certain things they don't want us to
announce
yeah I mean it's all in talks right
until they actually sign things and
whenever they when they sign things they
put an IMDb Pro or IMDb in general so
we can look when they actually sign
things
this person right yeah
you should ask them to get Harris to be
an actor in stock because he's the only
actor Among Us
I'll ask again I mean I want to be in it
as well but he's the only one without
any real talent there's nothing about a
promotion I've done for this I basically
am now in the opinion that this is only
happening because of basically me
and in that case I should be in it
I uh
to be Jay's American liaison for
anything and everything MGM if there's a
health and safety guy in this movie
when I put my hat in the ring for you
over here
shut up Matt
Just J being the new Sailor just
somewhere in the back just
seriously stuff as well getting
electrocuted in case and stuff
so get thrown across the gate yeah
I I am gonna have to ask but um but yes
Harris why not why not but
anyways Bach Jr I'm just saying Eris
Park Jr will be a thing we've got this
yeah it will be health and safety guy
will be back this week by the way
I've already done the video me and
Harris are doing a video as well but
Stargate Universe health and safety guys
coming
so I've sort of half written it and um
I'll try and get that done this week if
I can but then yeah me and you Harris we
need to get together this week and
finish that video let's do it so um
because you got the job look at little
Harris look he got the job so cute
um
what we're talking about but you got the
job well done
um
[Music]
another thing interesting happened this
week though that Matthew was quite
excited about
um
the new Doctor Who
dropped the new drop to remember
the trailer drops
not yet but the trailer dropped
um this is the first thing is this the
first thing they've done since the
Disney deal or was some of the stuff
they did or some of the last stuff
they've done
no this is this will be the first
production they're doing with Disney
because you know the one thing that I
really liked about the thing I thought I
was worried about
at least with you know Mo Money Mo
Problems sort of thing
um that it would look like an American
TV show and I was actually really
impressed
didn't it well it doesn't um
yeah
just it looks like they took the nice
cameras that they used for season 13.
um of Doctor Who and then used them
to film a good story
yeah oh my God
I like the last season it was it was it
wasn't great it was good
it looked great and that's what I liked
about it it looked really nice because
they upped the production quality they
got new fancy cameras and it was great
the story just lacked this looks like
they've just were like we've got the
cameras now let's write something really
good we've got David Tennant come on we
can do something good we can do
something good
is how much impact is like Doctor Who
got in America though
do you guys know it's coming is it with
the Disney deal is it do you care
I mean for for me you know I mean I see
announcements you know all over YouTube
and Facebook
that it's coming
um
other than it's coming I'm not really
sure where it's coming to because
there's so many places that have Doctor
Who there's a little bit Doctor Who on I
think is it Max and none others Doctor
Who on Pluto and then there's the whole
Doctor Who thing on Disney which I
really haven't sorted out in my head yet
but I was coming someplace and I'm sure
that I'll just keep logging on somebody
say oh my God it was the best episode
ever then I can go hunt it down
when the 60th anniversary drops which is
on November
25th I think
don't quote me on that but I think it's
November 25th that's really when the
first one drops it's going on Disney
plus worldwide so everyone can see at
the same time
Thanksgiving
is the BBC still involved with making
the Disney Doctor Who
yeah okay and you've got the bad wolf
but still sorry
as I understand it you know BBC's still
doing the production Disney's just doing
distribution oh cool yeah BK
yes they're not they're not produced but
they have given them a lot of money
it's the money injection it's the big
deal
um and that's what I was worried about
that they would
spend it
but not spend it well and what we want
them to do is spend it on improving a
little bit well we want to improve the
writing we want to get some better
actors in like
um Patrick Harris I've got Neil Patrick
Harris Neil Patrick Harris
um who I adore uh he was the best thing
in a million by a million miles about
the 10 things uh no sir How I Met Your
Mother
um a challenge
accepted
um it was about a million miles Barney
was the best thing
um it was really good in um Lemony
Snicket on Series of Unfortunate Events
he was big behind that he's already
produced it and everything he's not
um Cameo and Harold and Kumar Go to
White Castle is one of the best cameos
of anything ever he ended up cameo in
almost all of them and he's like oh he's
not really gay actually a massive
womanizer and he uses the gay thing to
get to mail them I love that they're all
so good the mushroom in White Castle
though that's
doesn't get better
Stargate Troopers you know
Troopers they don't do uh uh ayersbach
junior sign me up for Stargate Troopers
right now
right now come on
um so they've got um one of the main
character one of the main villains we
don't know if it's a villain yet it's
beat the Meep which is that big alien
with the big eyes it's a alien that come
from the comics like way back in the 60s
um that's making an appearance in the
60th anniversary and that is voiced by
Miriam Mark oils you know the one from
Harry Potter what's her name yeah she's
not snagged about a frogs that woman
she's crazy she's crazy
um yeah
Harry Potter what character Adams oh I
can't remember her name
um
yes yeah
that one
um
saying some things about uh
uh Charles Hayden Savage who plays uh
Steve uh Steve Martin she was saying
that he was all bad and little shops of
Horrors or whatever and the director was
like what the hell is this lady saying
like everybody loves Steve Martin like
he never did anything bad so I don't
know she's got herself in the in the
headlines right now she's she's a little
bit nuts
um
gloriously she's probably she's
eccentric because she's probably got
enough money to be eccentric which is
old enough but she is nuts you ever seen
her an interview she's like oh my God
you're on Graham Norton's show
it's so funny she's just the way she
tells are amazing it's so good but yeah
I'm excited that she's gonna be in it so
yeah I love that and I like saying Neil
Patrick Harris he's great and everything
so this is just this I think this is
glorious for him so um and we'll get a
nice transition from David Tennant to
shoot to get where and it'll be great
[__] by the way sex education Season
Three is out right now it is so good
it's so good
okay you watched it you don't watch it
oh you need to watch it it's so funny
it's really good they've gone yeah
don't wanna I don't want to see men's
Willies
don't watch the first episode then
that's really okay and the boys season
three episode one I was gonna say quick
cut this conversation on the bud because
I know what's coming in the comments
shortly
um what's coming Jay we're not saying
those words again all right so I can see
storm is praying ticking over because he
hasn't been listening and he's just
realized and no somebody said you know
first episode of
season three and there was a word in my
head did not intersect with my mouth
but I did think of butt plugs
God's sake
in that I was just like he's not gonna
do it that's great
damn it
um
sorry
plug it in plug it in you know you're
gonna have to make your shirt now Jake
right I love your enthusiasm there Bob
I'll tell you what mate I may as well
just do I might as well just do that
sometimes I just did that on t-shirt
right
what else you guys been watching this
week we're at the 50 minute Mark where
you know
scared for that question to be asked
after the conversation we just had
literally all this week I've just been
watching sex education and then bits of
Walking Dead that's pretty much it
yeah two very different jokes
because it sounds boring as crap it's a
comedy about comedy
well it's very big I guess it's about
two high schoolers one of them has a mom
who is a is she a therapist or a
psychologist or something like that
okay and she's specialized specializes
in sex education I my old roommate loved
it I've never watched a second of it I
love the cast but it's Otis oh this is
the guy his mom Jean is a sex therapist
and he's grown up with this all
throughout his life and he decides he's
going to start a free sex clinic at his
school
sex advice it's hilarious
um he has feelings for this this girl
called Maeve it's kind of will they
won't they get together kind of thing
and then eventually
things progress we're in season three
now uh shooting is in it he plays Eric
one of the best characters ever
I don't know if you ever saw it you know
coronavirus first happened people were
posting memes of our future Gap where
and it goes wash your hands you dirty
Pig I don't know if you ever saw it but
that was a quote directly from sex
education
someone in the comments has got to have
known
I can't be the only person watching sex
education I think we have a Sci-Fi
oriented audience here at Matt
um
there is an alien it's very strange or
I'll say alternative girl in season two
who has sex with an alien but not really
it's like
a tentacle dildo thing
I am definitely not watching this with
my kids
oh don't watch it with your kids
so the rescue is from the tentacle dildo
uh so why not watch this league
um I watched it it was kind of like a
thriller it's called night agent uh it
was about this uh FBI agent that uh
tracks down a mall in the white house it
was exceptionally good it was so good my
girlfriend mentioned that she was a want
to watch it um she was gonna she was
watching it um Friday night said I
should watch it so
I finished at 3 30 in the morning
watched the whole damn season 10 hours
it was really engaging so the second
season was green lit after the first
episode dropped really very happy
really really well done really well
um I watched a million miles away it's
about a migrant farmer that actually
became a space shuttle astronaut it's a
true
a fella that was in like Ant-Man it's my
opinion
my opinion yeah yeah yeah
is it based on true stories yeah true
story yeah yeah yeah
I also watched uh I got caught up with
uh Ashoka Ahsoka Ahsoka
oh my gosh it was just yeah the the
general thrawn thing and the just it was
excellent I loved it I can't wait to see
the next episode and I'll finish it this
week watching
um Amazon's Wheel of Time Wheel of Time
I couldn't watch it
I tried what episode are you up to are
you on season two or no I watched two
episodes of the first season and I gave
up
well you and I we can we both complained
about the production value of season one
season two of season one and how slow it
got and it was just
season two they dumped some money in and
it is I would say it has the production
has matured greatly
great
it and it actually started you know kind
of following the books things are
starting to make sense I mean it is I
mean The Wheel of Time series is like
what 14 volumes it was just they're all
about a thousand page thick it seemed
like it was really complicated it's a
really complicated story
uh so I mean one of my beefs is they
left out
um one of the main characters of the
gleman uh but it was second season is
astonishingly much better
uh than season one season one was
you know Season Two is is I so just over
season two episode one and see what you
think I I might make it more I'm gonna
give another try
um it can be my when I'm at work and I'm
not supposed to be watching TV TV show
I've seen more complicated struggling to
follow it and and so but
but I think they choked down
a lot of the story and it's uh
good so they listen to the audience
Amazon quite good at that they're quite
good at making mistakes but then they're
quite good at trying to fix them
um so we'll see
interesting things the power should be
very interesting see if they do with
that
um Harris well
I saw some good things I've been
catching up on Foundation I think I have
two episodes left of it for season two
and damn it's good I'm I'm getting to
the whole Harry salvar uh Gail and and
the the second Foundation kind of sort
of maybe I don't know I'm still figuring
that little bit out I'm enjoying that
little bit okay three episodes into the
second season so let's say too much okay
it just gets in the whole Harry
storyline nothing's great I I need more
people to watch this it's one of the
best it might be one of the top three or
four shows on television right now and I
know so few people are watching I'm just
glad Apple's still willing to back it
the way they are because I mean the best
sci-fi trilogies of the 20th century and
so the whole Foundation I mean it was
just you know I mentioned
what a [__] but so good yes
you would have loved it I don't remember
what's I don't know if it was a here or
M cubed or what uh but last week or the
week before stormy someone mentioned
Olive Foundation I'm just like here let
me go grab all my asthma books and I
grab like 13 books and I was like this
is a stormy pile right here
uh besides Foundation been watching
Futurama
cool and I'm a Futurama shield and it's
still just not doing it for me like it
it it needs to go to sci-fi cool
Concepts have fun it's just it
everything they've been doing it could
just be in a Simpsons episode it's just
modern it's just making fun of modern
stuff this is based three a thousand
years in the future do something cool
that's all I'm asking come on well I
just finished this enchantment from the
same people which is one of the best
sitcoms
[Music]
you haven't seen the new episode no I
haven't seen any of them yet I keep
going I've started to watch the first
episode about four times and something
always jumps in but more wonderful
anyone wants it she didn't really like
the first season so the season might be
my favorite Meryl Streep was the perfect
person to add into this I need to get
like
there's one episode left
one episode for the season they're only
like 40 minute episodes don't they so I
can binge it yeah
uh besides that Ahsoka and then I did go
see bottoms again which is hilarious go
check it out if you haven't seen it of
course but
I saw probably the worst movie I've seen
in a movie theater and I don't know
a long time and I was excited for it I
got properly baked prior to this because
I was expecting to need that and it
didn't even help the way I thought it
would and as much as I'm a fan of every
single person in the cast
Expendables Expendables 4 was so bad
so bad like like oh oh there were a few
moments where I'll reiterate I was
properly baked going into this so my
mind was in a special place I was like
okay this is gonna be some dumb fun
whoopty woo within about 30 seconds of
walking in and sitting down I was like
that's CGI that oh oh I just kept making
little noises like that to myself and I
was like this is not gonna be a fun two
hours
um CGI that bad all the way through
who the hell is producing these things
it is so unpolished unfinished they
shouldn't have released this movie they
should have released maybe in three
months
yeah it's you know and like um on a
Friday afternoon and you're at work you
can't do the stormy because planes you
know spaceships will explode but most
people you know you get to that Friday
afternoon and you sort of like
uh I'll do sorry
um you know and it's like I'm I'm the
weekend's here that'll do yeah
it feels like a that'll do movie
it feels like with a lot of this a lot
of the the writing as well to be honest
in bits it felt like that'll do the the
dialogue was quite literally I don't
know a better word for it than atrocious
it was it was
like it was written like a five-year-old
had written it
um it was just bad and he's in Jason
Statham who I adore was bad in it yeah
everybody was and and I mean I don't
want to give a spoiler away or anything
but like
something may happen to Sylvester
Stallone a little bit and and they have
to kind of put someone else in charge of
the group for a for the time being
and wouldn't you think it would be Jason
Statham or Randy Couture or literally
Dolph Lundgren or any of these people
that have been there or you know just
just give it to Megan Fox that makes
sense let's just oh let's give anything
to make a fox I would give her whatever
she wanted
uh
it's awful I'm still making weird noises
just just being so sad from it
it's not the lowest I mean none of these
films are Shakespeare don't get me wrong
no they're very much
but you know a look who we've got rather
than look at the story but this is just
like they went look who we've got should
we do a story now screw it well I mean
at least even with it not not being
Shakespeare not being Oscar worthy
they're not they're not going after any
awards that's for damn sure no they they
still had
that there was some depth not a whole
bunch of it but there were some depth it
was like this these aging dudes that are
still very capable of doing a lot of
things just not as capable of doing
things in the way they're used to trying
to find cool and interesting ways to
still keep up with the Joneses in a way
and with this they were just like yeah
we got young people now we're gonna make
a couple jokes about being old and it's
not going to pertain to anything and
keep on kicking
just there's there's no heart there's no
soul there's nothing because that's the
first three had some heart and soul this
was just like
well at least you can just enjoy the
cast explode it's just even the action's
kind of stupid
whole film's too stupid mangoa made fast
X great not great but it made it like
watchable like you watched it you're
like okay well now I'm with Momoa you
know I'm having fun now that I'm
watching on this side there wasn't a
character like that in here there wasn't
anyone to latch onto or grab onto to to
just enjoy it so I sometimes wish I had
an erase button you know just like to
Boop I raised the last two hours of my
life you know sometimes when I have
arguments with the kids and things just
go I'll just pretend that didn't happen
um or you know whatever and that's what
I wanted to just go all right
helps but uh well I forgot it pretty
quickly let's go back to Foundation
quickly because I've I'm loving
Foundation I put a comment on because I
did the video I can't remember why I was
talking about foundation in the video
actually
um but um and I said I think they've
been really loyal to the
um original books
and a lot of people jumped and I go wow
this changes they change that they
changed and I was like no no I don't
mean they like have made a series that
follows the books because they haven't
because the foundation would be
impossible to do that
but I think they've actually done
something that is loyal
overall story The feel the tone
um and what the story is trying to say
and I don't know they change things like
you know the um Emperor and stuff like
they changed bits about that but they've
done it so that it makes sense but also
it does seem to think that people don't
understand like the practicalities of
making a TV series that you can't
you know have a million actors in these
things that you have to actually like
have a cast and that you know you I mean
somebody mentioned it in the comments
earlier that you know it's it's a bit
you shouldn't have TV series that you
have to research beforehand for Ashoka
oh Ahsoka
um because certain characters are like
why is this important and if you didn't
watch some of the cartoons you'd have no
clue something and I might get that but
with a foundation it's such a
complicated story I don't know what
people expect
um but I I don't know what you guys
think I haven't watched it I thought it
was like I read the books years ago so
don't get me wrong I can't remember
big chunks of the storyline
um from reading the books I just I I
recognized
the the story so I mean I was just like
oh I remember that in the book and I
remember you know what I mean
um what do you guys think of you I mean
how's stormy you've read him I know
you've heard him for me it was like when
I first read it I said this will never
be uh anything you know it's just always
going to be in book form because it's
the scale of it in terms of time is like
there's gonna be so many characters and
there has to be so many leads and so
forth that the audience is gonna be I
mean they skip one episode they're
totally lost
you know as you filter through the
events of foundation and then get in the
second Foundation but the the way they
came up with it with you know Dawn day
and Dusk and keeping the same characters
and or the same actors and then keeping
Don day and dusk with the same themes of
attitude and whatever which is bloody
brilliant I mean it was really
creative you know now and and the way
they're handling Harry Selden and
everybody else is just
that was really smart yeah it gets to
the point of the book but in a way that
you actually do and that's what I was
trying to get to I was trying to say
that this is very very clever how
they've done this and it's taken a lot
of effort I think and they really do
should be applauded for it but there's
some people that are going it's
different
can you imagine how difficult it must
have been to to appeal to the Asimov
family
yeah there he goes
yeah there you go yeah yeah
put that narratively on TV yeah
difference Paris though but it was it's
I think it's a really loyal adaptation
because they have
worked really hard on this to make it
still foundation and recognizable as the
foundation
um but in a way that's possible to
actually do
something
big game no uh if it weren't
done the way that they've chosen to do
it we would either have it would almost
feel like black mirror in a way where
every single episode would have an
entire different cast it would feel very
conceptual and you there are ways to do
it but there are no ways to do it within
excuse me actual narrative
and and have it feel comfortable in that
sense like black like doing it in a
Black Mirror style would have been
really cool
but you would you would have lost
everybody so quickly yeah the the only
person in in that kind of uh chronology
if you want to do it that way that would
have been the same would have been lady
dimrzel really that's like your your
option that's that's your only
consistent casting absolutely true and
it would it wouldn't be as as much as I
I love these novels they're all amazing
Isaac Asimov is great these every single
one of these fantastic in its own right
you you would be bored as hell trying to
watch that on screen and piece it
together without having uh an invented
for film
cleonic Dynasty I I feel like it's just
it's a way to bridge the gap between the
books and the the
medium of film I guess is a good way of
saying that instead of actually just
trying to adapt it precisely it just
wouldn't be
be fun to watch there's nothing about it
that would be fun and that's coming from
Sci-fi channel that loves this kind of
stuff you know like
I'm really really impressed the way
they've done it to to to make it doable
um safely Monk's just been talking about
sliders getting a reboot they tried a
couple of years ago
um it came quite close
um but uh that's not gonna happen
Quantum Leap I think is um the success
of Quantum Leap has basically made the
slide as well happen because it's too
similar so
um but I've got a video coming out
Tuesday now probably about a bunch of
reboots that are quite exciting so if it
happens which I don't think it will but
anyway
um space 1999 space 20 25 yeah
um but there are a couple there are a
lot of conversations about
um rebooting some old TV shows at the
moment because I think executives are
just sort of sat around twiddling their
thumbs trying to figure out
what to do in the next 12 months so
there's lots of stupid ideas being
bounced around so we'll see what happens
guys thank you so much we've gone past
the hour on ten so
um
stormy got anything saved up I was like
what's he thinking
well you know
I do like Foundation
yeah there you go good but I will I will
say
um Ahsoka it is man that last episode
was just
awesome holy [__] it was just I still
can't get over I I can't get over it uh
from someone who has not have you seen
Rebels stormy
oh I've I've seen half of it I've seen
half okay okay so you have watched okay
because I just have to do a little
Ahsoka defense
you know get yeah
yeah uh yeah people are saying like oh I
don't know who these people are you have
to do homework to watch it no you don't
doesn't it make it 10 times more
intriguing to watch it without knowing
exactly who these people are you're
learning about them on the way and I
think there's Intrigue still I guess I
mean I think it was written and shot and
and uh acted for somebody you didn't
have to go back and do you know a bunch
of research yeah yeah I feel like the
ones that are complaining about that
just feel left out and hey you don't
have to feel left out you can go watch
Rebels any day of the week any day of
the week any hour of the day yeah and if
not hey sit back relax and you're gonna
learn who thrawn is You're Gonna Learn
who Ezra is
and we get to learn how that's going to
happen together it's gonna be pretty
damn cool with me is it as sure that she
was off searching for
the only thing with that for me was that
was a big deal and the whole episode was
Ezra's if you and I I I've not watched
those cartoons after items I have no
clue where there is and if you don't
know it is a bit drawn out it does go on
a bit you're just like who is this
person and why should I care yeah the
last episode went on and on and on about
and she's willing to sacrifice herself
for this person and if you haven't seen
the cartoons it doesn't really make
sense
well it'll make sense
it will make sense and that's the thing
it's
if you don't want to do that you got to
look at the the person who's making this
itself Dave filoni is a slow burner
everything he's ever done Star Wars the
Clone Wars avatar The Last Airbender
Star Wars Rebels all of it takes its
sweet time the bad imagination I love
that [__] oh it makes it so much more
rewarding and and sure people can be
pissy people were pissy the first season
of Clone Wars people were pissy the
first season of rebels people have been
pissy the first season of Ahsoka and I
cannot wait to see what people say in
about a year and a half busy about
everything you know we don't have any
patience we're so used to Tick-Tock and
just every freaking second something new
in front of your face go the hell damn
slow the hell down breathe a little bit
meditate a little bit like your old Jedi
do and just sit back relax and enjoy
what's being brought to you sometimes
you know for those of us that saw
episode four of Star Wars A New Hope
when it came out in the theaters
originally
we were grateful that we got to see the
next one within just a few years yeah
freaked out and it you know and you know
The Empire Strikes Back was probably one
of the best of the franchise I mean oh
my oh my that was a good movie
they got there and the rebels got their
asses kicked and talk about your Slow
Burn uh-huh you know literally nothing's
resolved at the end of the movie like
just okay
so Harris got a question for you or just
I got two look for you
Turtle people
we start talking about Pokemon now or
what no no no we're still talking about
uh
what about them I I like the nodi
so cool oh my God awesome it felt very
lucas-esque and that makes me feel happy
it was like it was like the I thought
they were the Ewoks of the uh of the
amphibious world
yes it felt like it and it feels like
they're a little smarter than the Ewoks
generally too which is nice yeah they've
already got gizmos and Technology you
know and you know
office I'm intrigued that they're they
almost seem like hard foots
in that way were there they're traveling
but in that snails
playing shut up
[Laughter]
I'm enjoying Ahsoka but that's enough
now okay real Star Wars
you don't care look you've made Sarah
getting sleepy
um
[Music]
Amazon executive has contacted us and
told us this target is coming back
it's okay we had to wake up after Doctor
Who it's okay guys thank you so much if
you are late rewind the first 20 minutes
of this video if you're a Stargate fan
is very very interesting please go and
have a look and tell your friends please
like share all that sort of stuff for
the video because this is the stuff
we're at Stargate fans need to know this
stuff now because we're actually telling
you and we've been telling you for two
years and there are still people that
doubt us and it really winds me up but
um
let's let's let's get this information
out there uh there will be a story on
the side Trek
um
so guys thank you so much everybody in
the con in the chat thank you so much
again and um yeah see you next week
bye adios goodbye everybody Goodbye Oh I
should really do the ending credit you
think you know anything okay
[Music]
no I wasn't letting that go
did you see how